Good morning, everyone. I think we'll go ahead and get started.
Thanks for grabbing your coffees and getting here early for this 8:00 AM session.
We appreciate it. This is
Educational Session Two, Senescence in Cancer. I'll be your chair.
I'm Marcus Versetti, coming from UMass Chan Medical School.
Just to go over some logistics, this is a 90-minute session broken into
30-minute increments. Each speaker will have 20 minutes presentation,
10 minutes for question. And we encourage a lot of discussion, so please either
come up to the mics for the question, or you can scan this QR code
or use the app and we can read your questions online as well.
So we encourage you to have a great discussion with us.
One little hiccup, so unfortunately,
Jennifer, who was our first speaker, had an issue with her flight, so she can't
make it in person, but luckily, she was able to record her talk.
So you'll see her recorded talk. And Drew Pardal, one of her colleagues,
will be answering questions for her.
So we really appreciate Drew stepping in.
And I'm also joined by my colleague, Clement Smith, as well.
Just a quick intro to senescence. We know the field has really
changed dramatically over the last 20 years.
First described as a cell cycle arrest pathway, we know it to be a
potent tissue remodeler, immune remodeler with both pro and
anti-tumorigenic effects in cancer.
The development of single-cell and spatial technologies now, and also senescence
reporter mice, have really allowed us to dive in to this heterogeneity where we can
find basically any cell in the body can undergo senescence
from stresses we get every day or stresses that accumulate over a lifetime,
and they can impact cancer therapies as well.
So our hope is that dissecting the mechanisms by which senescent cells contribute
to progression or clearance, we can design rational therapies you might have heard
of called senolytics or senomorphics to target senescence to make it
more tumor suppressive.
As you'll see from the speakers today, I think it also takes a lot of
multidisciplinary approaches from different cancer spaces to really
tackle this complex question of
senescence in cancer.
So we will get started with our first talk today from Dr.
Jennifer Elisseeff, who is Professor of Biomedical Engineering at John Hopkins
University. Her talk will be a great intro to our
session on defining senescence and implications for cancer.
Good morning. I'm sorry I'm not there in person.
I had some flight challenges on the last flights
heading from East Coast. So, unfortunately, I'm
recording, not there in person, but I did plant a collaborator
in the audience
to answer any questions that may come up.
But I'm really happy to be able to share
our work today in the field of senescence.
Here are my current conflicts and previous conflicts,
partially related to the presentation.
So I'd like to present a little bit of background first,
our approaches in tissue engineering,
because they really influence how we approach senescence.
And then talk about our work in senescence in articular
trauma and arthritis and fibrosis.
And from that experience, how it led us to look at ways
we can better define what is a senescent cell and the concept of
senotypes.
And finally,
I'll discuss senescence and what we've learned in those other models and
the potential implications in cancer.
So I come from the tissue engineering field, as I mentioned,
and we spent many years looking at biomaterials that could serve as
scaffolds for things like stem cells, and that we could
integrate biological signals into these materials.
And I mention particular stem cells because that really has guided a lot our
concept of cell states and proliferation versus
differentiation. A cell that's proliferating
usually doesn't differentiate, and when we think of a senescent cell
that's secreting actively lots of factors, it's really in a
differentiated state.
So we translated technologies in the area of cartilage and
soft tissue fillers,
and these experiences in the clinic really guided us to the immune system
and the concept of regenerative immunotherapies.
So today, we think of tissue engineering as manipulating immune stromal
networks that are sensing and regulating tissue structure,
and you'll see that senescence plays a role here, and we think it's an interesting
node and a hub for these
interactions. So we first started characterizing what is a
natural immune response after tissue injury, and
what does it look like in a healing wound versus a non-healing wound
characterized by fibrosis and inflammation, and can we use this information
to redirect that non-healing wound to a healing environment?
And this has applications in cartilage and fibrosis,
and
we recognize that the tumor was described many years ago as
a non-healing wound.
In a healing wound, we can look at things like muscle and pro-regenerative
therapies that are stimulating repair, but then work has shown
that tumors that are responsive to therapies such as
immune checkpoint blockade have a phenotype of
wound healing and wound resolution.
So if we look at wound healing and kinetics, the wound-healing process has been
well-characterized in the context of the immune system, stem
cell mobilization, wound closure.
But senescence is also a part of the wound-healing
process.
So in a healing wound,
you'll have senescence initially increase and then decrease.
But in a non-healing wound or a wound characterized by chronic
inflammation, senescence or markers of senescence remain
high.So senescence in hard-to-repair
tissues. As I mentioned, we started in cartilage repair for a tissue
engineering application, but we recognized even if we had a
perfect therapy to rebuild tissues, if there was inflammation,
such as interleukin-1 beta, it would not repair very well.
The tissue engineering wouldn't work.
At the same time, collaborators
Nat David had recognized that senescent cells could be an interesting
therapeutic target
for a number of applications, in particular osteoarthritis, where
senescent cells had been seen in cartilage explants being taken
from patients undergoing knee or hip replacement.
So what is a senescent cell? Well, the history of the field
has really looked at senescence in
vitro. So first looking at the Hayflick
limit and replicative senescence.
So after cells have been cultured for a long time, they stop
proliferating, as is connected with
decrease in telomeres.
It was also recognized there was stress-induced senescence that could
be stimulated by oxidative stress, genotoxic, and
oncogenic stress, and the proliferative stress being
another mechanism. But much of this has been studied
in vitro.
So these cells were characterized with a number of markers.
So
beta-gal, for example,
HMGB1, movement from the nucleus to the
cytoplasm, and p16,
cell cycle
related gene, was seen to be upregulated in some cells,
although well recognized to be an imperfect marker.
But many of the tools are built around p16.
So these cells are in growth arrest, but they are secreting a
senescence-associated secretary phenotype.
This SASP is what is implicated in the function of
these cells to increase tumor
production or related to the
diseases associated with aging, such as heart disease, diabetes,
and arthritis, as I mentioned. However, these cells are also
recognized to be an important part of embryological development and tissue
repair. So how are these cells both good and bad?
Well, research has shown that senescent cells are a part of wound
healing,
and that is through secretion of PDGF,
platelet-derived growth factor.
And then our work on senescence as an example where
the accumulation of senescence is associated with
disease in the joint and arthritis.
So from the arthritis perspective,
we looked at an injury, anterior cruciate ligament
transection, where the cartilage lining the
surface of the joints degenerates after that injury.
It's a chronic wound.
Senescent cells, as I mentioned, were recognized to be a part of
the arthritis process. And when we did
senolysis or removal of senescent cells, either through molecules
or through transgenic animals, we could
restore the cartilage. And we
observed reduction of SASP factors, reduction of pain, and we were very
surprised, we also saw an increase in tissue repair when those
senescent cells were removed.
Now, luckily, I had an immunology collaborator who recognized some of these
SASP markers, IL-6 and IL-1 beta, and told us,
"Well, these molecules are connected to T cell differentiation."
So we looked in that same model and saw increases in
IL-17, both in the joint and
in the draining lymph nodes,
increasing with injury and disease.
And when senolytics were added in both young and aged animals, a
decrease in IL-17. So there seemed to be a connection between
senescence and IL-17. So to further explore this, we
induced senescence artificially in vitro and cultured
these cells next to naive T cells. And in the presence
of TGF-beta, we see a significant increase in IL-17
production by these T cells.
We also took Th17 cells
that we skewed in vitro and cultured them next to healthy fibroblasts and saw
an increase in p16 and SASP factors, including
IL-6.
And we phenotyped these cells a little bit more and have
a signature of an inflammatory-induced senescence from this in
vitro model. So we can use inflammation as an
additional mechanism for induction of senescence that may
be more physiologically relevant than some of the others that I
listed before.
So again, when we think of tissue structure, this communication between the immune
system and the stroma that's regulating the matrix
and vascularity, senescent cells are playing a big role in that
interaction.
Now, continuing on the matrix discussion of tissue
structure, senescence is associated with fibrosis
in murine models and in human tissues.
These are markers for p16 and p21,
so associated with fibrotic diseases in these tissues.
And we can see in other fibrosis models, this is
a fibrosis around breast implant,
and p16 is in pink here, and we can see p16 cells
stretched out with a fibroblastic
morphology. We also see p16 cells
around the vasculature that is adjacent
to this fibrosis.
So we're interested in this network and understanding what a senescent cell is,
and we're a part of the SenNet program at NIH
that's looking to define what a senescent cell is in vivo
in tissues,
in both mouse and human tissues.So we first
used the biomaterial model to study fibrosis,
and this is a nice reproducible model where we can get consistent
fibrosis. We have the same inflammation and abnormal vascularity.
And you can see here that we have red p16 positive cells sort
of adjacent to macrophages
associated with the
fibrosis stretched out again like a myofibroblast.
But then we also see some associated with vascular structures, and you'll
see that this is a common theme.
So,
yes, single cell, of course, is popular, and sometimes you can see
p16 expression in single cell, particularly with the
newer
techniques. But in general, it can be hard to find p16, and again, as I
mentioned, it's not
a completely accurate model of marker for senescence.
So in these fibrosis models,
we can
look at the cell types there.
But in order to really capture p16 cells,
we used a genetic model
developed by Jan van Deursen and Darren Baker, p16 Cre.
And with our biomaterial model, we could see that, number one,
as it's recognized in the field, a small number of senescent cells
are present. And when we look further at
which cell types are senescent, we see a lot of stromal cells
that are senescent, CD45 negative and
CD29 positive and CD31
negative. There are also some I'll show you later
in the tumor model that are CD31 positive.
So when we pull out and sort just that subset of senescence,
CD29 positive, we can perform bulk sequencing
and get a signature which we call senescence signature.
And when we look at what's there, we saw a lot of markers,
enrichment in vascular-associated
genes, but also chondrocyte differentiation genes.
And while we worked on cartilage before, this is not a cartilage environment.
When we look at how we can capture and identify senescence in
single cell, we use transfer learning to then look at that
signature, and in each cell, is that
cell similar or different
to that signature? So we can see senesc positive cells.
This is the fibroblast population here, both activated and
myofibroblasts. And then we see pericytes, a smooth
muscle cell population that's also senescent.
If we look at markers of these cells, in particular
SAS factors in these subtypes, we can start getting phenotypic
information of the activated fibroblasts versus the
myofibroblasts. There's also an inflammatory fibroblast and a
perivascular senescent cell or pericyte, which each
senescent cell is expressing different markers.
But
single cell and the clustering is a way to bin cells into a
certain phenotype,
but it doesn't tell us much about patterns.
So working with Ilana Furtak, we used her CO-GAPS
program using non-negative matrix factorization to
instead look for patterns of gene expression that can
cross these cell identification clustering.
And so we see patterns of gene expression within those senescent
cell types, and we can connect that
with spatial data to start seeing these niches
where
the senescent cells are and which cells are around there.
So we have a fibrotic niche, a vascular niche, and an immune niche.
And the cartilage niche is in the fibrosis, but it's
expressing markers that are typically associated with cartilage and tendon
tissue, which is avascular, similar to fibrosis.
So just to give a summary, and
this will be a preprint soon, we can look at transcription
factors, cell surface markers that might be unique to these
different subtypes of senescent cells, and SAS factors
that can be associated with extracellular matrix,
matrix degradation,
immune factors, and growth factors
of these different senescent cells or senotypes.
Now we're very interested in how these cells are communicating.
So senescent cells are a particular node
in the network of cell communication.
So we use a program that we developed called Domino Signal,
which looks at transcription factor activation
associated with receptors, and then connecting
that with ligand expression. So a little bit moving backwards compared to some
other standard receptor ligand programs.
Now if we look at this in a muscle repair model, so good repair in a young
animal versus poor repair in an old model.
If we look in a young animal at communication, here's our senescent subtypes down
here, we can see communication through a number of
cell types,
the immune cells, vascular cells.
But in the old animal, it's really taken over by T cells, and
this cartilage-like are really highly fibrotic cell types.
So the senescent cell type and its communication is
important.
Now finally, interest here
with tumors, the tumor microenvironment being characterized as a non-healing
wound. Matt Wolf has done work looking at,
for example, the lung tumor biopsy where we can see p16
positive cells in the stroma where there's
fibrosis, so the pink cells here. And these are different than, of
course, the tumor-associated senescence, which has
been
studied.And here's a close-up of these fibroblasts.
But we still see these vascular-associated cells.
And in the tumor model, we do see some senescent
endothelial cells and pericytes.
But I'm going to talk about something a little bit different.
We see senescence also in fibroids,
where we, again, have the fibroblast, vascular-associated
in combination. So it's important when we talk about senescence in the tumor
environment, that there are multiple senotypes.
And the matrix these cells produce is important for
enhancing tissue mechanics. For example, a fibroid is much stiffer
with that increased senescence. And you're up-regulating
mechanosensing related transcription factors.
So we can build this model with our networks to look at communication.
This is an example in the fibroid of senescence immune
factors that are modulating the immune system and bringing in the immune cells,
vascular-associated factors, again, contributing to both
fibrosis and to the immune cell
migration.
But I mentioned early on, can senescence be beneficial,
and what are the implications here?
So,
we looked at senescence in the context of different
wounds and its association with immunotherapy response.
So cancer immunotherapy has clearly been transformative,
but many patients do not respond. So understanding
why these patients don't respond and the mechanisms of resistance
may help guide us in improving the
impact of immunotherapies.
So we were interested, coming from the wound healing tissue engineering
perspective, how different injuries might impact the response of
a distal tumor to immunotherapy. We looked, for
example, at a muscle wound. That's a preprint that is available.
So muscle wound will increase tumor growth and decrease
responsiveness to immunotherapy.
And the other wound model that we know how to do in the laboratory, as you know, is
an arthritis model. So we tear the ACL
at various time points before injecting a tumor.
And what we found that opposite to the muscle wound, that
the articular injury
decreases tumor growth a little bit, but actually has a
significantly great increase in response to immunotherapy.
So a B16 tumor model,
you see the tumor growth curve. When we have that articular
injury and arthritis development,
we see a significant reduction in tumor volume and
increase in survival.
How does this happen? Well, we first looked just at T cells.
So this model is not very
immunogenic. So
in standard tumor model, we do not see many T cells.
But when we have that articular injury, we see more T cells in that
tumor environment. And these
CD8 cells are tumor-specific using the
B16-OVA model.
When we look at
vascular changes, we see some interesting differences
here. So the tumor vasculature in the ACL wound,
we looked at pericytes and endothelial cells,
and you can see they're tightly associated with the
arthritis. Without the arthritis, we have a gap and
sort of a different stabilization or structure of that vessel.
And we see more P-selectin in those
vascular structures.
So this obviously connects with that increased T cell infiltration.
Now, we did look if the draining lymph node was required, and it wasn't.
So then we further analyzed the serum with and without that
arthritic injury and the tumor, and we
saw significant increases in pathways associated with
extracellular matrix organization, in particular vascular development and tissue
development.
When we look at single-cell analysis
of these
tumors, we were surprised that the P16
positive cells were not the ones that
were positive for P-selectin. So this again shows the importance of
communication here, where P16 positive cells
were the senescent cells,
but were activating
a subpopulation. And this is true for both the endothelial
cells and the mature pericytes.
So that communication is important, and we have a number of candidates that might
be responsible for this.
If we look at the vascular structure more broadly, you can
see
the vessels are larger and more stable with that arthritic injury,
and we have increased P16. So the red here,
hopefully, you can see,
with the pericytes and the endothelial cells, none really
associated in the tumor itself, but really associated
with the vasculature. And in the no surgery, just
regular B16 tumor, you see very few vessels,
less structure, and no senescence.
And what's interesting, if we look at the perivascular cells and the
endothelial cells
with and without the arthritis, without arthritis, we
have lots of genes associated with hypoxia and vascular
development, VEGF production. So these cells are giving the signals,
but the vessels just are not forming.
And then in the perivascular and endothelial cells,
we see the senescence
upregulation.Now, looking up
closely, you can see better here the pericytes
and endothelial cells that are senescent.
If we use the Incatak model to genetically delete senescent
cells, you can see we lose the phenotype of
the vessel structure, and we lose the phenotype of
the T cell infiltration and P-selectin, and our
tumors are
no longer responding to immunotherapy.
So I think I've reached my time limit, and I know virtual presentations
are not quite as fun as in person. So I'd like to summarize that
senescent cells can have many phenotypes, and the field and SenNet
community is terming this senotypes.
There'll be a review on this coming out in Nature Aging from the SenNet
Consortium soon. These senotypes reside in different niches
that help regulate tissue structure, and that tissue structure
connects with the extracellular matrix production
and things like fibrosis, but also the vascular structure and immune.
And depending on the senotype,
these cells can be beneficial
or detrimental to many different things, wound healing
and tumor biology and response. In addition to the senotype, it's also the
kinetics. So, early on in a wound, for example, you do need
some matrix production to rebuild the tissue, but chronic presence of those
cells is associated with that fibrosis and disease.
And I just wanted to mention one thing, bringing in sort of an
interdisciplinary perspective.
There's an interesting article that came out
a number of years ago. You could see it took a little while to come out, 2021, it's
a 2025 publication. And this article describes the
pivot penalty in research
when you change fields. And
we often think about
interdisciplinary work and innovation happening at the intersection of
fields,
and we need that to have discoveries, but there's a
penalty with that,
with publication citations, and
grant funding, and things like that.
So, let's consider as we bring in all these different perspectives.
Many people to thank
for the hard work on this, and collaborators,
and in particular, the SenNet program, which
has
generated a lot of collaborations and interest in the field of
senescence. So, thank you for the opportunity to
present, and
I hope you have a wonderful rest of the session, and feel free to reach out by
email
if you have any other specific questions.
So, thank you very much for your attention.
All right. So we have about five minutes for questions that I mentioned.
Drew Pardal,
Jennifer's collaborator, is willing to come up and answer some of those questions,
but I think Clemens and I could also answer some senescence questions as
well, if you have them.
Instead of answering questions to Jennifer's talk, I would like to ask the
first question-
... while you are still going to the microphones.
Drew, the last point was truly interesting and a bit
provocative. Can you give us more insights what it's
needed on the osteoarthritis side in terms of
inflammation versus senescent cells?
And on the other side, seeing that there is an enrichment of
neoantigen-specific T cells in the tumor now equipped with
more angiogenesis, do the endothelial cells now serve
as cross-presenters of that neoantigen in the tumor?
So this is one of the elements that I
can speak to.
So
this is still very
early,
but this is
what we know and also what we don't know relative to these questions.
So,
what
Jennifer didn't show in the interest of time was
that if one uses a genetic
senescence deletion model, so deleting
P16-positive cells that can be induced
by a drug,
the anti-tumor effects of checkpoint blockade are
mitigated. So,
at least based on the definition, imperfect as it
is, but not bad, of a senescent cell,
that is certainly necessary.
One also sees, of course, in this OA model
and in human OA, senescent cells in the
joint.
And so one of the
questions that's not resolved is if you eliminate senescent cells, how much of
that is that you eliminate SASP
components produced
by the senescent cells in the joint versus
components produced by the senescent
pericytes in the tumor that are driving
this
normalization of vasculature
P-select activation, P-selectin
upregulation, and that translates into about a
five to eightfold increase in traffic
of lymphocytes out of the vasculature and
into the tumor. Interestingly, the transcriptional
programs of those lymphocytes
in the tumor aren't that different between ACLT versus
non-ACLT. So it really looks like a numbers game
related to these alterations in the vasculature.
But what the relative role is of SASP components versus other
inflammatory
componentsStill not worked out, and
that's obviously a major
area moving forward.
Also, Jennifer didn't show
an analysis of some of the Hopkins
checkpoint blockade clinical databases.
And certainly,
if you have OA going into your anti-PD-1
therapy, actually your
outcomes are dramatically better
than if you don't. So this is good for somebody who has OA in their
hips. This is the first positive thing associated with
that.
We'll take a question over here.
Yeah. Thank you so much. This was a great talk.
My question is regarding the integration of senotypes,
as they're called, and temporality with SASP.
So is it such that different senotypes have
different temporal evolutions? I mean, canonically, the
understanding is that in the early stages of SASP, you have a much more
acute inflammatory sort of response versus this chronic
inflammatory state that may be less beneficial in the context
of tumor progression and response to therapy.
So is there an integration between senotypes and that temporal evolution?
Yeah. So this is a great question, and I
think there's still relatively little that's known.
So the variables are
the cell that is producing the SASP, and different cell types,
clearly different senotypes, call them.
There are core components. So IL-6 and
IL-8 are examples of--
They're fairly core to senescent cells of
different types. And then there are also very
distinct
SASP elements that are cell type specific.
So there's
cell type. There is location.
Some of these factors
really can have systemic effects, but others of them,
like IL-6 as an example,
is a cytokine that acts relatively locally
in that the concentration by the time you're
eight to 10 cell diameters away from the cell
producing it,
that concentration is too low to be triggering the IL-6
receptor.
And then there's time.
And
again, they're interrelated because one of the things that in some of
these models that Jennifer sees is that the
change in SASP with time is associated
with ultimately loss of certain
populations of senescent cells and other population, other senotypes
coming up.
So I think this is a hugely
ripe area for the next 5 years of-- 10
years
of investigation. And as Jennifer mentioned,
there
are actually some really
impressive mouse tools,
genetically modified mouse tools,
that are available to be able
to assess these questions.
Excellent. Thank you.
So we just have time for one quick question over here.
I think mine is quick. I'm coming from outside this field, and what I wondered is
whether the senescent signatures that are being generated give us
improved markers to use in in vitro
systems.
So this is about can we
develop better senescence markers?
Yeah. And I wondered if that had emerged from the signatures.
Yeah. So,
absolutely. And
certainly,
in looking at senescent cells by single
cell, really signatures composed of multiple
components and this transfer learning approach of
defining signatures
in the mouse and looking at correlative cell types
and settings in the human,
I think that's going to be something that takes us a lot further than just
p16, for sure.
All right. We're going to move on to the next talk.
Let's thank Drew for answering our questions and being a real trooper there.
As you'll see, you'll have time for other questions as we go through some of these
other talks. So
Jennifer really gave a nice background on senotypes, introduced this
concept of the senescence-associated secretory phenotype, or SASP.
In my talk, I'm going to dig deeper into the SASP, particularly how it affects both
cytotoxic lymphocytes as well as myeloid cells in both immune
supporting and suppressive ways.
And by understanding that regulation of the SASP, can we design therapies
called senomorphics to remodel the SASP to get better immune
responses and immunotherapy responses in cancer?
These are my disclosures, though they're not relevant to this talk.
So as Jennifer had alluded to, senescence goes beyond just aging, what Hayflick and
Moorhead first defined it as. It's really a
conserved physiological stress response to damage.
There are a number of stimuli that can induce it, telomere shortening, DNA
damage, reactive oxygen species, common oncogenes such as
RAS, and common conventional cancer therapies like chemo and
radiotherapy. The first really solid intrinsic hallmark that
I think most of us are aware of is this stable cell cycle arrest that's
mediated by these two tumor suppressor pathways, p53 driving p21
and p16 by inhibiting CDK4/6 kinase activity,
activating Rb to both transcriptionally and epigenetically
repress cell cycle genes.In addition to these cells being arrested, they're
also persistent because they're resistant to cell
death, such as apoptosis, by upregulating anti-apoptotic
pathways such as BCL2 family members.
Given these cells don't proliferate and they upregulate tumor suppressors, it was
first surmised that this is a tumor-suppressive process.
Indeed, there are a number of landmark studies in 2005, including from Dr.
Smith's lab. They really were able to identify markers of oncogene-induced
senescence in non-proliferative premalignant lesions.
So what do we mean by that? So here's an example, KRAS-driven lung cancer from
Manu Serrano's group. So on the right here, we have an adenoma.
This is a premalignant lesion, hasn't become invasive yet.
On the left here, we have an adenocarcinoma, which is considered malignant.
Using this canonical marker of senescence, senescence-associated beta-gal,
we can see the premalignant lesion stains beautifully for SA-beta-gal, but
as the tumor progresses, it loses this senescence marker.
And there's been really nice mouse models here from the Pandolfi lab in a different
model here in prostate cancer losing PTEN to activate the
PI3K pathway in these premalignant intraepithelial
neoplasias, again, staining beautifully for beta-gal, and then
having the need for additional tumor suppressor loss to bypass senescence,
suggesting this might be a barrier to full malignancy.
However, as we went into the 2010s and beyond, the development of a number of
mouse models using two of our most canonical markers of senescence,
p16 and p21, to track these to temporarily and
spatially deplete them, and development of drugs called senolytic
drugs to target these anti-apoptotic pathways or
P53 pathways that allow senescent cells to persist,
showed the exact opposite, that actually senolysis or removal of
senescence can block tumor progression and relapse after therapy.
So how can senescence have this paradoxical role?
So there could be a number of reasons.
As Jennifer alluded to,
perhaps cells other than tumor cells are undergoing senescence and they're
causing tumor promotion, and I'll get to that towards the end of my talk.
You'll hear from Dr. Smith perhaps senescent cells aren't totally
irreversibly arrested and could eventually proliferate again.
But what my talk will focus on is the SAS, the ability of these damaged
cells to convey their damage signals to the microenvironment.
And the reason why the SAS might induce this paradoxical role of
senescence, it has a lot of pleiotropy.
There are a lot of different types of factors included in this secretome.
These include proinflammatory cytokines, IL-1 alpha-beta, IL-6,
chemokines like CCL2, but also growth factors
and matrix metalloproteases that degrade the extracellular matrix,
angiogenic factors such as VEGF, PDGFs, and
also prostaglandins and other lipid species.
And it's important to note that in addition to these secreted factors, senescent
cells upregulate immunomodulatory receptors and ligands on
their surface that can have immune consequences.
For instance, activating NK cell ligands, activate NK cell surveillance,
MHC class II expression of antigens that activate CD8 T cells, but
also immunoevasive molecules such as PD-L1.
And the SAS is regulated dynamically by the number of different transcription
factors listed here. My talk, I'll focus on two of the more
inflammatory ones, NF-kappa B and c-Gas, seeing the drive
downstream IRFs and type I interferon signaling.
We also know that there's also epigenetic regulation and enhancer remodeling to
open up these loci as well as increase protein translation to drive the
SAS.
And so really, Judy Campisi, I believe, is the one who coined SAS as this
double-edged sword in cancer. On the one hand, as Jennifer
alluded to, the SAS can lead to fibrosis resolution, it can lead to wound
closure,
and it can also lead to attracting immune cells that come in and clear out that
damage. But as the SAS lingers, for instance, during aging or other
chronic diseases, that inflammation can be inherently immunosuppressive.
It can also drive angiogenesis as well as invasion and proliferation of adjacent
tumor cells.
And so we really think this gets into this idea of acute versus chronic SAS.
If you can acutely activate an immune response with a SAS that come in and clear
out that damage, this can be tumor suppressive.
But if this lingers, eventually the SAS can give rise to progression.
So what I'll give you now is a few vignettes from my work and other works
alluding to these tumor-suppressive and promoting aspects of the SAS, and then dig
into how my lab has sort of looked into how the SAS is regulated and how
we can push this response more to being tumor suppressive.
So a number of works, particularly in hepatocellular carcinoma, have really shown
us that senescent cells can be immunogenic, capable of both innate and
adaptive immune surveillance. This is a work from Wen Xu, Lars
Zeuner when they were in Scott Lowe's group.
This is a model of HCC where P53 can be turned on or off with an
shRNA. Reactivating P53 in the context of RAS
mutations can induce senescence, as shown here by beta-gal.
This can regress the tumors. And they showed that this was due to, at
least here, innate immune activation, neutrophils, macrophages,
and NK cells, induced in part by these SAS molecules shown here.
So this SAS can induce innate immune surveillance to regress
established tumors. More recently, Scott Lowe's group has looked
actually not at the secretome, but at the surfaceome of senescent cells, what is
on their surface that's upregulated.
They found the interferon gamma receptor is highly upregulated on
senescent cells. Why that's of consequence?
Because interferon gamma in the microenvironment can bind these
receptors and activate increased MHC-1, which can
lead to better antigen presentation in the tumor, reprogram macrophages
and also dendritic cells to be more antigen-presenting, and thereby also
activating adaptive CD8 T cell surveillance.
And a back-to-back paper that came out from Manu Serrano's group even showed
that you could inject these senescent cells as a vaccine
into mice as a prophylactic. So if you injected these cells, then
transplanted a tumor, the tumor never formed.
Again, showing that senescent cells can be inherently
immunogenic.And there's also the context of acute
therapy-induced senescence from many different types of therapies.
So this is really nice work from Jim Jackson's group looking at chemotherapy in
breast cancer models. They showed that downstream of NF-kappa B
and IRFs, a number of immunomodulatory receptors upregulating,
including a number of different immune checkpoints.
And they found by combining chemotherapy with
anti PD-1 plus anti-CTLA4, which
are immune checkpoints, they can get better tumor responses in this breast
cancer model.
I also showed similar things when I was a postdoc in Scott Lowe's group in the
setting of RAS-driven pancreas cancer.
We found that a combination of palbociclib, a CDK4/6
inhibitor, and trametinib, a MEK inhibitor, could potently inhibit downstream
RAS signaling to induce an Rb-mediated version of senescence.
Interesting and similar to
Jennifer's talk, we actually found the SAS in pancreas cancer was very angiogenic.
There are lots of VEGFs, PDGFs secreted.
This lead not only to increased vasculature, but better endothelial activation
marked by P-selectin, VCAM, increased MHC II, that
led to the increased infiltration of CD8 T cells.
However, those T cells weren't really active.
They upregulated PD-1 and the senescent cells themselves, though
upregulating MHC I also simultaneously upregulated
PD-L1 checkpoint. And we found that combining TP to induce
senescence with anti PD-1 could at least lead to partial regressions
in this model.
So that's with acute senescence. But if we go back to this acute
versus chronic scenario, I think it's a good example to look
in the setting of oncogene-induced senescence.
So this has really been work by Lars Zender's group here.
They overexpress NRAS in hepatocytes to induce senescence.
You can see these are senescent at day six. By day 16, they're gone.
And they found that a combination of macrophages and CD4 T cells could
eradicate these hepatocytes that are senescent before they can go
on to form tumors. And from SAS profiling, they found that
CCL2 seemed to be a main driver, particularly of the
macrophage phenotype.
But in later work from the Zender group, they also looked in more established
HCC. And this is just a schematic describing that actually that chronic
CCL2 that initially led to clearance early on,
actually promoted the infiltration of immature myeloid cells, what some may
call MDSCs, that actually inhibit macrophage
differentiation and inhibited NK cells.
So I think this is a good example of how chronic SAS can eventually
be tumor promoting.
And others have shown this. Really nice work from Sheila Stewart and others have
shown particularly fibroblasts can secrete what I would call more of this
pro-myeloid SAS, CCL2, IL-6, CXCL1
and 2, that promote these suppressive myeloid cells that can be tumor
promoting.
A nice example is here in the setting of prostate cancer from Andre Almonte's
group. In this model, either of oncogene-induced senescence or
chemo-induced senescence, the SAS heavily upregulated
CXCL2, which drove in the infiltration of TAMS and
also MDSCs expressing its receptor CXCR2.
And Johan de Bono in the UK turned this into a clinical trial.
So he looked at this high neutrophil to lymphocyte ratio, which is
usually a marker of poor treatment outcomes and immune suppression.
He found that high neutrophil to lymphocyte ratios correlated with different
SAS markers, NF-kappa B, CXCL2, amongst
others, and even enrolled patients with castration-resistant prostate
cancer, which is the most aggressive form in hormone refractory portion
of the disease with CXCR2 inhibitors and can get responses.
So this is just SAS chronically can exist even beyond
oncogene-induced senescence and could be targeted as a xenomorphic approach.
And so when I started my lab in 2020, we were interested in really understanding
this dichotomy of SAS, how it's regulated, how can we harness it
for cancer immunotherapy. So some questions we were
after that I'll get to in my talk. One, which SAS factors are actually
important for antitumor immune responses? Here are just some of them.
Some of them I mentioned implicated in activating NK cells and T cells,
other myeloid cells. Ones in gray are very pleiotropic, they can do
multiple things depending on the context.
And can we harness just the SAS to activate, in particular, these cytotoxic
lymphocytes, NK cells, and CD8 T cells that we know are important for
antitumor immunity?
Second, how is the SAS transcriptionally regulated?
I mentioned NF-kappa B and STING are two of these more pro-inflammatory
transcriptional regulators, but there have been many implicated.
For instance, P38 MAPKs known to inhibit interferon signaling.
Notches are known to drive a more TGF-beta-rich
ECM remodeling SAS. In addition to the transcriptional regulation, we know
that there's also dynamic epigenetic regulation as well
that's worth exploring.
And finally, how does the senescence inducer, meaning, for instance, the type of
therapy or oncogene-induced senescence, the cell type,
whether it's a tumor or non-tumor cell, and the resident microenvironment
impact the SAS, and from that, its impact on immunity?
So to get at that latter question, we did this interesting experiment where we
treated
mice with the same drug, but in different cancer contexts.
So we went back to this trametinib, which is a MEK inhibitor palbociclib
CDK4/6 inhibitor-induced senescence.
We did this in KRAS-driven lung cancer models.
Saw this nice NK cell response mediated by SAS factors like
CCL2 and IL-15 that could attract NK cells, that could
bind to the cell adhesion molecule ICAM-1 upregulated on senescent
cells, leading to regressions that could be reversed by giving an
NK1.1 blocking antibody. We also tested in a
very similar genetic model, still KRAS, mutant and PD3 deficient, but now
pancreas cancer.
But we did not see the same inflammatory SAS induced.
We did not see the same NK cell responses, and we did not see tumor
regressionSo we're curious about this phenotype and digging deeper into
that. First postdoc in my lab, Lo, really did this really cool
experiment to try to address this question.
She took mouse tumor cells that were from pancreas cancer, lung cancer, and she
injected them into different organ sites.
So she either injected them into the pancreas or tail vein injected these to form
tumors in the lung, sorted out just the GFP tumor cells, looked at the
SAS profile and found in this setting where pancreas
tumors are grown in the pancreas microenvironment, they did
not have the same SAS as seen in other organs.
IL-15 and 18 that are important for NK and T cell activity, and
CXCL10 and 11 that are important for their chemotaxis.
Digging deeper in doing transcription factor motif analysis, she found of the
differentially expressed genes in the pancreas, EZH2 was a top
regulator. And EZH2 forms this PRC2 complex that
leads to H3K27 trimethylation, which is a repressive
chromatin mark. So could EZH2 upregulation of the pancreas lead to SAS
suppression and hence NK cell inhibition?
So she used shRNAs to knock down EZH2 in the tumor cells.
We injected them, treated with these drugs, induced senescence.
Now massive upregulation of the SAS, including many of these
chemokines here that I mentioned are usually not induced in the pancreas
microenvironment. With that, better NK cell infiltration, early activation
markers. Here, six out of seven mice had complete responses now with
knocking down EZH2 that could be completely reversed by
depleting NK cells. So this we found was a way by taking off this
epigenetic break to activate this inflammatory SAS, particularly
chemokines, to activate NK cell immunity.
But we're interested in the other side of the coin.
What's so different about lung cancer compared to pancreas?
Not surprisingly, some of the top transcription factor bindings were from RelA,
which is the p65 subunit of NF-kappa B, and a number of IRFs
that can drive downstream interferon signaling.
So we thought, could we find a way to activate interferon signaling that's induced
in the lung but not in the pancreas?
To do that, we collaborated with Pravana Teegala Raleigh's group at UMass Amherst.
They had made a lipid nanoparticle containing CDGMP, a
STING agonist, and MPLA, a TLR4 agonist.
She had previously shown the combination of these two pathways could
synergistically activate IRF3
downstream to drive this type I interferon response.
This is just showing that we can actually deliver these nanoparticles by tail vein
injection and deliver them into the pancreas microenvironment.
And with that, these orange bars indicate the combination of inducing senescence
and activating IRFs could induce more interferon beta, IL-15,
and other chemokines usually repressed.
We also did long-term treatment responses in genetically engineered mouse models of
pancreas cancer that form spontaneous tumors.
While we did see some NK cell activity, we saw more of actually a CD8 T
cell-driven response, as shown here.
And while each modality alone could increase survival, we saw massive survival
increases combining TP to induce senescence with these STING TLR4
agonist nanoparticles, including two complete responses that unfortunately
relapsed off of drug, but still driving the proof of concept
that activating the SAS, particularly the type I interferon arm, could be
a way to lead to durable immune responses in pancreas cancer.
And indeed, using an IFNAR antibody, which blocks a type I interferon receptor,
we could reverse the T cell activity.
So to summarize this portion, we know many different drugs can induce senescence,
but they don't all induce the same SAS.
We found that targeting EZH2 to take off the epigenetic brakes or targeting
STING TLR4 agonists to activate the type I interferon arm
of the SAS could activate both NK cells and CD8 T cells
in pancreas cancer, leading to tumor regressions in this very
immunologically excluded tumor type.
But we're also interested in how different classes of therapies could
modulate the SAS. So Lynn Joe, a former postdoc in my lab,
did this in the setting of prostate cancer.
This is just showing the different types of inhibitors she used, not only CDK and
MEK inhibitors, but also a number of DNA-damaging agents, PARP
inhibitor, aurora kinase, and conventional chemotherapies.
What I hope you appreciate here is TP can induce some senescence, but these
DNA-damaging agents seem to induce a much more robust
senescence phenotype as shown by assay beta-gal, and also a much more
robust SAS, both quantitatively and also
qualitatively different, driving more of what I would call this pro-myeloid
SAS of CSF, CXCL1, and CXCL2, particularly with
this
chemotherapy known as docetaxel.
Doing RNA-seq, she dug deeper into this and actually found an addition to
inflammatory signaling pathways being upregulated with DNA-damaging
agents versus CDK inhibitors. Also ECM remodeling SAS,
including MMPs, TGF-beta, that are known to remodel the
ECM, but also drive what's known as EMT, which is a driver of
invasion and metastasis. And indeed, in mouse prostate cancer
models, docetaxel, which can induce senescence, can decrease primary
tumor growth, but it has no effect on metastasis.
And so she looked at what was upregulated with docetaxel.
Not surprisingly, as I mentioned, BCL2 is this anti-apoptotic protein
upregulated in senescence, but also IAP, inhibitor of
apoptosis. And so she used these senolytic approaches to target these
pro-survival pathways. This is showing we can induce
cell death and decrease the p16 burden with these
approaches. But interestingly, she found the mechanism of action was a little bit
different between these senolytic approaches, with IAP antagonists
not only inducing apoptosis, but an inflammatory version of cell death
known as necroptosis. And with that in particular, she can not only reduce this
myeloid chemokines, but actually also induce some of these
pro-lymphocyte chemokines with that immunogenic cell death.
And with that, with these senolytic approaches, activate more T
cells, reduce immature myeloid cells, enhance
antigen presentation by DCs, and now reduce metastasis.
So this shows us that senolytic approaches could takeCare of this sort of
ECM remodeling SASP by removing those senescent cells, and also
suggests that the type of cell death induced by senolytic might induce
different immune responses downstream of the SASP.
And finally, we wanted to also get at how the cell type undergoing
senescence also impacts the SASP.
So Lynn, in a work published earlier this year, in her early model
of prostate cancer, this oncogene-induced senescence, she found that p16 and
p21 that we typically use interchangeably as senescence
markers actually marked different senescence populations.
p16 really marking epithelial tumor cells in the
glandular structure, but p21 marking more stromal cells.
Collaborating with my former PhD mentor, Hong Wu, we did single-cell analysis
and found that CDKN2A, which encodes p16, was really in the
epithelium, but p21 was expressed more broadly, including in
myeloid cells and fibroblasts. And just to break down this busy
figure, what we found by looking at the SASP was the epithelial compartment really
wasn't expressing much. Fibroblasts, a little bit of TGF-beta and VEGF,
but really it was the myeloid cells secreting predominantly this
SASP. So senescing cells in the microenvironment might induce a different
SASP, it might be tumor-promoting.
To prove that functionally, we did this experiment where we transplanted a
syngeneic prostate cancer cell line into this p21-RTTA
model developed by Sundeep Khosla's lab here.
p21 drives an inducible caspase VIII that allows you to give this
pro-drug to remove any p21 cell. But because we're
injecting a tumor cell line that doesn't have that allele, we'll only get rid of
p21 in the microenvironment, not on the tumor per se.
And with that, we can activate T cells, reduce immature myeloid cells,
leads to tumor growth suppression, and importantly, block the SASP.
We think the microenvironment SASP, perhaps because it's chronic, perhaps because
it's more pro-myeloid, seems to be tumor promoting.
And I'll just mention, we're not the only ones who have shown this.
There are many in the field to look at this sort of non-tumor senescence.
Darren Baker's group has shown this nicely in macrophages in lung cancer.
Sheila Stewart's group has shown this in fibroblasts in breast cancer.
And Andrea Alanti has shown this in neutrophils in prostate cancer.
So there are many different cell types that can undergo senescence.
This has really changed our thinking of senescence beyond the tumor and thinking
about, could this stromal senescence be a link between stress, chronic
inflammation, and cancer? Especially if you think of an aging individual
accumulating senescent cell, could the senescent cell accumulation
in benign tissues during aging create a soil for tumor
propagation?
So that's a nice thought, but we need a number of next steps in the field to really
get to this point. We need better biomarkers to
distinguish these senotypes, but also these different flavors
of SASP. And from that, we'll need to design more specific senolytic and
also senomorphic targets to target this pathological
senescence. And we'll also acquire deeper characterization of how senescence
and immune cells interact, particularly in niches, in particular at a spatial
level.
So to summarize the key points, what we found is that innate adaptive immune
system can mediate potent clearance of senescent premalignant as well as
established tumors through the SASP, through things like chemokine
CXCL9 and 10, interleukins, interferons, but also have
regulation of ligands that can activate NK cells and MHC class
I molecules. We also know a chronic SASP can lead to myeloid-mediated immune
suppression through factors such as IL-6 and CXCL1 and 2.
And that SASP-mediated immune responses in cancer are dependent on a number of
things.
The resident makeup of the tumor microenvironment,
the chromatin landscape of the tumor cells, particularly these marks that
regulate enhancer remodeling,
and the SASP transcriptional programs. I mentioned a few of these.
We looked at pro-angiogenic that induce blood vessel formation,
pro-lymphocyte that activate NK and T cells, pro-myeloid, and also
ECM remodeling that could potentially drive metastasis.
And it's also dependent on the therapy, whether we're talking about a cytostatic
CDK inhibitor or cytotoxic chemotherapy can induce different
SASP, and whether this is in a tumor cell or whether this is a stromal or
immune cell undergoing senescence. And I'll leave you with this.
I think senomorphic approaches to enhance type I interferon
arm of SASP while suppressing the pro-myeloid SASP will maximize
immunogenicity of senescence for cancer immunotherapy.
So I'll just stop there and really acknowledge our lab, our great collaborators,
mentors, and we're hiring at all levels if anyone's interested in joining our
group, and I'm happy to take questions. Thanks.
Thanks.
Thanks, Marcus. That's not on?
I don't know.
Okay. Thanks, Marcus, for a great presentation.
We have time for one or two quick questions.
Hi, good morning, Marcus. My name is Jelani Zarif from Johns Hopkins.
Great talk. I was wondering about your experiments using the MycAP
models.
Yeah.
Were those animals-- And then you used the MP10.
Were they castrated after tumor
implantation? Those are castration sensitive.
That's a great question. P10 we did, and that was a reviewer question.
It might've been you. But we did it.
No. It wasn't me.
It's in the paper. So we actually had a better phenotype when we castrated the P10
model. But they're de novo resistant. They'll start growing immediately.
So there's not a
dip in a growth. They just keep growing. But they do even better.
MycAP we didn't because we're a little bit afraid because if you remove
androgen, you're going to also inhibit Myc, right?
So I try to stay away from castrating the MycAP model.
And then on top of that, you used the ABT inhibitor,
I think in the MycAP model.
Mm-hmm.
Have you all combined that with the anti-PD-1 therapy,
given that you saw a large influx of cytotoxic T cells based
on your staining?
Yeah, we haven't done that yet. That would be a really cool thing to do, but we
haven't. Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
Yeah.
Sheila
Hey, Marcus. A great talk. So I understand this is a loaded question before I ask
it, but when we think about P21 versus P16 senescence, admitting there's
probably many more, do you think that it's more about
cell specificity and/or temporally?
Like one comes before the other-
Ooh.
... like in a GEM model.
My guess is temporal. My guess is that either
tumor-secreted factors or SAS, I think P21 is a secondary
senescent. I think it's secondary induced by acute
stress, and they become hyper-inflammatory.
It could also be induced by the microenvironment.
They're getting into a hypoxic microenvironment.
So my hypothesis would be that it's temporal, but we haven't proven
that yet.
Very last question, Barry.
Yeah.
Quick, please.
Beautiful talk. I'm an immunologist, and this is new to me, so my brain is just-
Mm-hmm
... going crazy now.
And I was just wondering, beautiful mouse models, but have you kind of
put the pieces together to look in the cancer atlas in
patients to kind of understand where the jump is in
terms of how much we could harness in patients here?
I see. So translating what we're doing in the mouse model to the patients.
Yeah.
Yeah. We're wanting to do that. It's a little bit tricky.
Some of the therapies like chemo, we can do.
I think Clemens has really been the pioneer in the field of translating this
into patients, so I think he can speak more to that.
Maybe he will during his talk. But we haven't been able to yet.
It's really hard to, I think--
Some of these markers are difficult to stain for.
It's also hard to know fixed sections, where the signals
are coming from, and how they change over time.
So we would love to get there and love any suggestions from anyone in the audience,
but I think Clemens is probably the best person to answer that.
Maybe he will during his talk.
Thank you.
Yep.
All
right. So we'll move on to- Our third and final talk
from Dr. Clemens Schmidt, who's professor at Charité University of Berlin, Max
Delbrück Center of Molecular Medicine in Berlin, and Johann Kepler University in
Linz. And we're looking forward to your talk. Thanks.
All right. Thanks very much. Let me start off by thanking the ACR, the organizers,
for selecting a presentation from my lab
for this highly informative educational session on
cellular senescence.
So here are my disclosures. And I can only thank the previous
speakers for so well introducing the topic that
there's not much to add, but a little bit.
In the clinic, we often don't know whether we look at a wound or
cancer. So as obviously as we learned from the previous presentations, an
intimate relationship between derailed wound healing and
cancer. So senescent cells, as we all know, are an
intrinsic component of the multicellularity of
cancer as an organ. But I like to make the point, although it was
pointed out by my previous colleagues,
that in an acute fashion, senescent cells in wound
healing are an essential component for proper wound healing.
So the components listed here following the tissue injury,
primary senescence, then SAS-mediated secondary senescence
to take care of all damaged cells, not to
propagate any more and to contribute to the parenchymal
cellularity, is followed by
SASP-called immune cell invasion to
clear up the injured site. But there's also
translational reprogramming into
senescence-associated stemness, which sounds paradoxical,
but in proper wound healing, it's the senescent cells which
therefore may contribute to replenish cellularity
once stresses have been resolved.
And with this in mind, we may now look at
senescence-promoted cancer features with some different
perspective. In particular, looking at senescent cells not only
as the source of SAS, but also being
reprogrammed latent stem cells. And if this
happens hijacked by a tumor, they may become de
novo cancer stem cells. So with this, that's already obvious,
I think, to this audience, there is, in an acute fashion, in
response to activated oncogenes or in response
to antineoplastic therapy, a beneficial
tumor-suppressive form of senescence.
But if those therapy-exposed senescent
cells or oncogene-activated cells persist, then they may
drive derailed wound healing inflammation.
They are reprogrammed as stem cells.
And if they get permission to occasionally re-enter the
cell cycle, they may exert their stem-like function.
There's immunogenic plasticity, immune evasion.
We heard about this, and therefore, there are
possible therapeutic interventions.
We heard about senomorphics to limit, in particular, inflammation, and
senolytics to actually catch the senescent
cells at their root and eliminate them.
I'd like to make a point which, in my view, is obvious but is
not really deeply discussed. Senescence is not a binary
state. It's not in or out of senescence.
There is a pro-senescent trigger driving a cell into
senescence. And actually, it may matter over time how
long, how strong, and in what kind of trigger this trigger is
applying to cause maybe initial senescence, light
senescence, actual senescence, and perhaps something like
super senescence. I'm not showing data on this, but I like to make this
point that the depth of senescence, particularly at the level
of epigenomic reprogramming, chromatin remodeling, in particular, the
senescence-associated heterochromatin foci
may decide about the quality of senescence and
its depth, and in other words, what was already quoted before,
reversibility of senescence. I would not claim
senescence is reversible. I believe it's neither reversible
nor irreversible, but there is a state beyond senescence.
I like to share that with you. We have data why we believe this is not
philosophical, so that if senescence is
reversible, it was not senescence.
If you have a cell deeply in senescence, and here's the
machinery inaugurated by Monsieur Shin Narita in Scott Lowe, the
SAFmachinery. E2F target genes are
deeply silenced by an histone H3
lysine 9 trimethylated mechanism.
We concluded if we would provide in senescence a
demethylase activity, we may be able to
drive cells out of senescence. That's what you see on the right side.
If we induce Jumonji D2C, these firmly
RAS-induced senescent cells can level off, become
pS2 beta negative, and can reproliferate.
And the mechanism behind is
turnover of nucleosomes. This has to be
permanently reestablished. So we allowed an H3
arginine 9 mutant to compete with H3 lysine
9, and you see it takes a while, but after a while there
is an overtake of the R9 mutant, which can
obviously not lysine 9 trimethylate, and that's sufficient to
allow, again, senescent cells to get out of senescence.
And you see these senescent cells have now a reduced load of
H3 lysine 9 tri-methylation. We
heard a lot about heterogeneity of senescence, and I think that's super important
because the field is moving into single-cell omics
technologies and tries to describe the various
facets and types of senescence. I like to discuss with you whether
there might be rather one full-featured uniform
program that provides
certain aspects in different contexts.
So it's more or less the same senescence program, which is
associated with key functionalities in given cellular
context. Other features are present but less relevant.
Or whether there are indeed multiple or many distinct types
of senescence characterized by different lead functions where other
features are less present. I'm not concluding either
of the two is right. I guess it's a spectrum in between, but
it's important for therapeutic interventions.
So there is a core senescence machinery and a specialized
machinery, which would mean if you look at a rather uniform senescence
program, it's driven by the core machinery.
If it's more a specialized program, it's driven by these
additional lead functions. Core senescence markers we
know, it's complicated enough to detect them or to determine
whether a cell fulfills a sufficient amount of these
markers or is positive for certain signatures, as we heard
today. So this is complicated. But if we look at the more
specialized senescence markers, we would have
type-specific senescence vulnerabilities as compared
to targeting the core machinery in terms of a shared
senescence vulnerability. So the more uniform
program is good and bad senescence throughout the body, while the
more diverse or multiple types of senescence may
give you specific senescence functions and you may argue, I
understand that from a clinical perspective, you want to target the bad
ones and want to leave the good ones intact.
Whether that's achievable, that's a different question.
I'm not making an argument for either point, but
I like to go for the second half of the talk through an
intense analytic approach where I share with you the addressing
of a rather uniform aspect of cellular senescence and what
the consequences of this might be.
Before we get to this,
looking at senolytics, what will happen?
In acute senescence, or senescence in
an acute fashion, I think we agree on this, is rather a beneficial
program, and there is stemness associated with
senescence in wound healing. There is immunosurveillance of
senescent cells. But if senescence gets chronic, it's typically
detrimental. I already referred to cancer
cell-associated stemness, loss of functional parenchyma,
and others before have
talked about organ fibrosis. So if we eliminate
the beneficial acute senescence, we may
have problems. We may impair stem cell compartments.
We compromise regeneration or may attenuate immunity.
That needs to be seen. In the chronic detrimental senescence,
that's obviously the space in which we like to eliminate
senescent cells in order to see anti-aging
effects, fibrolytic effects, and anti-cancer effects.
So if I could choose, I would try to optimize
dose scheduling in order to leave
senescence beneficial in the first place and
apply senolysis in a scenario where I can eliminate
those which dictate unwanted disease
pathologies. So that's what we aim for, to control
cancer,
actually even prevent cancer, and attenuate aging by
pan-senolytic approach. And I'd like to share with you how we
harness the redox imbalance in senescent cells for
senolysis and what the clinical effects in
preclinical models might be. For this, we teamed up with a
medicinal chemist from the Free University in Berlin, Jörg Rademann,
and colleagues, and set up a redox-based drug screen
because we came across metabolic
imbalances in senescent cells driven by
NADH as a background, which could allow us to
screen for an oxidative activation of candidate
drugs in order to produce further oxidative stress to
selectively eliminate senescent cells.
So get a dual selectivity of an agent, which is now called
Senlytic, for the elimination of senescent cells.
So this agent we retrieved from the drug screen, Senlytic, is
indeed activated by NADH. You see the higher the
NADH we provide, the higher thePeroxide
H2O2 output is, and this is countered by
GSH. So in conclusion, high NADH, low
GSH levels would activate this agent.
And since it's producing peroxide, if we overexpress catalase,
we reduce peroxide production, and we limit
the cytotoxic efficacy of this agent.
We made a derivative which is no longer activated by
NADH. It's the de-Senlyt, the blue line, and you see this
has no senolytic potential as compared to the original
compound, the red line.
Here you look at a number of senescent scenarios, therapy-induced,
oncogene-induced, oncogene inhibition-induced senescence.
And the common feature of all these senescent types is
this altered NADH/GSH
ratio across the cell types.
Notice that senescent cells have an elevated pool
of labile iron, and this LIP can be
measured by Ferro-Orange. And you see that across
different senescence inductions, we see this
elevated pool. But senescent cells are protected from
ferroptosis. We are coming to this in a second.
If we provide a chelator here, Desferrioxamine, we can
reduce these lipid iron pools. So if we
use Senlyt, we can,
in a dose-dependent manner, increase reactive oxygen
species. You see in the upper left the lysosomal ROS or
right, the mitochondrial ROS. It's the red lines to focus on for
now. And lipid peroxidation increases or
is increased, as I said, in senescent cells, and that can be
utilized on the lower right by Senlyt to kill
these cells out of this
latent ferroptotic state. If we use another
iron chelator here, B-pyridone, BIPI, the blue
lines you see we reduce ROS production in
response to Senlyt. We get less lipid
peroxidation, and we don't see a senolytic effect.
So this concludes that Senlyt helps to utilize
iron in the so-called Fenton reaction to produce
OH radicals and to kill. But I like to mention
that another arm of killing by Senlyt is
via classic apoptosis, as blockable here
by cVAD-fmk. But in conclusion, we
use two modes of cell death, ferroptosis and apoptosis,
and even strongly apoptotically compromised tumor cells can
still be killed via the ferroptotic pathway.
Senlyt has high senescent selectivity.
You look at four scenarios, non-malignant settings or tumor settings
in the mouse or in the human species.
And you can see from all these graphs that there is a huge
senolytic index and great advantage to selectively
kill senescent cells as compared to proliferating cells.
That's reiterated here. It's difficult to read curve, sorry
about this, but what it tells us is that
Senlyt is at least as good or better, obviously,
than other established senolytics in killing at low
concentration senescent cells, but with limited
toxicity to their proliferating counterparts.
And there's a genetic senescence dependency if we test
p53-proficient versus p53-deficient cells.
It's the proficient and senescence-capable, but not the senescence-incapable
cells we can kill by this agent. Just to go through
a few more vignettes, this is replicative senescence in a
setting where we have cells arresting after a certain number
of divisions as compared to HTERT positive cells.
It's only the RS cells which can be killed.
We look at virus-induced senescence.
Some cells can undergo virus-induced senescence. You see that on the left.
Others don't, and only those which undergo this are
susceptible to Senlyt. That might be the most important slide of the
presentation for Senlyt, because you look at virtually all kinds of
cellular senescence we tested, and whenever we achieve to
drive cells into senescence, you see a blue
square to depict senescence. And it's only in those
settings where dose-dependent application of Senlyt will
result in profound cell death.
We can eliminate aged cells. Here, this is an example of
lung fibrosis in old mice. Again, to remind you, there is
equally an altered GSH/NADH ratio in
these aged lungs. The aged lungs are characterized by
high-level p16-positive cells and H3K9
trimethylation-positive cells, and these cells account for
collagen cuffs around the bronchioli.
And if we apply Senlyt to those aged animals, we not
only remove the senescent cells, which is nice to see
inside you, we also reduce the collagen cuffs, which
is interesting because apparently you can eliminate senescent cells, and by
the endogenous fibrolytic activity of the body, you
even reduce collagen cuffs. So that's a demonstration of in
vivo clearance of senescent cells.
Senlyt is of very limited toxicity, to say the
least. We don't see differences in body weight.
We don't see differences across major cardinal
lab or cell blood cell parameters.
We can use Senlyt as an augmentative or consolidative
agent upon chemotherapy. You look here at chemotherapy or
TIS in a lymphoma model where only
p53-proficient lymphoma cells with an apoptotic block
underwent cellular senescence.And if we take those cells, apply
senlytic, we kill the senescent, but not the equally treated
p53-deficient cells. And we can test that in vivo.
We administer lymphoma cells, lymphomas grow in
recipient fully immune competent mice, and then we first
apply chemotherapy and second senlytic.
And it's senlytic which in senescent lymphomas,
extends survival of the mice in virtually all settings.
But if we use p53 null lymphomas, the addition of a second
drug here, senlytic, is ineffective.
We can look at oncogene-induced senescence, first in vitro.
We take MEFs from LSL,
MEFs and activate their BRAF. Then they turn
senescent, and we can eliminate them by senlytic.
We can do this in vivo in these very same mice, in which
we activate BRAF by provision of
hydroxy tamoxifen, CRE is activated, BRAF is on, we
get nevus cell nevi pigmented skin lesions.
You see that in the middle. And if we provide senlytic, we can
reduce these p16-positive lesions.
That is particularly nice to look at the ears of these mice, you see these
dark spots in the ear, and if you provide senlytic, they
disappear again. So another example for in vivo
clearance of senescent cells. We can drive this a step further,
and that's a pretty interesting model.
Based on tamoxifen, we can turn on BRAF.
But we can use tamoxifen in addition in this compound mouse
containing two p53 ER alleles
to restore functional wild-type
similar p53 levels. In this setting, we get the same result as
you just saw, but we have the opportunity to remove
tamoxifen at some point in time, which means that there are
BRAF-positive lesions now no longer with active
p53, therefore on their way to form melanomas.
And that's indeed what's happening in this model.
You see the lesion at the back of the mouse.
You see the skin tumor, and you can even see metastasis to inguinal
lymph nodes in the lung. But if we now in this window of
opportunity where we have only OIS nevus lesions
provide senlytic, the result is the following.
We see delayed and reduced melanoma genesis in
this model due to senlytic.
We can also target RAS senescent cells.
This is simply retroviral provision of oncogenic
RAS. And you see on the left, we can provide senlytic and eliminate
those cells. If we do RAS activation in
p53-deficient cells, there is no effect of senlytic.
The interesting point is now using an old-fashioned
chemical cancerogene, NMU, N-methyl-N-nitrosourea,
because that causes RAS mutations from endogenous
alleles. The result is same. We see senescence in
response to NMU, and this senescence can be eliminated
by senlytic only in p53 proficient cells.
Now we took this to the next level and did this in vivo.
So we treated mice, normal C57 black 6 mice with
NMU. We get, among other things, RAS
activating mutations. And all these mice will succumb to
T-cell lymphomas in a limited period of time, as
you can see. If you use a background here, Suva
minus mice, which can no longer establish this H3K9
trimethylation mark. So they get instantly with no tumor
blocking senescence, these T-cell lymphomas.
If you do this in wild-type mice, it's much less
impressive. About half of the mice will get over time
T-cell lymphomas because there's a senescence barrier.
But if you now provide senlytic after NMU provision to
these mice, you virtually prevent tumor formation
from incipient RAS lesions in
this animal. So with this, let me conclude that we look
at senlytic as a novel compound class that is activated
by and kills via senescence-associated oxidative
stress. It has senolytic activity across virtually all types
of senescence with no obvious systemic
toxicity. It extends lifespan, I didn't show that, and
attenuates age-related pathologies.
Prolonged survival after debulking chemotherapy, limits the
progression of BRAF positive nevi to full-blown
melanoma, eliminates OIS restored melanoma.
I didn't show that, but you see the bullet point here.
And it prevents RAS-driven tumor formation by eliminating
incipient OIS lesions. So in summary, what does it mean for
senolysis and pre-cancer?
We can target an universal core feature of senescent
cells here, and metabolic imbalance by an pan-senolytic
that's feasible and effective. And using a short pulse dose
schedule achieves clearance of senescent cells in vivo,
whose proof is in clinical routine, certainly not trivial.
Pan-senolysis covers multiple detrimental features
of senescence, and I'm not seeing an advantage
of a more selective senolytic approach, and that's of course open to a
controversial discussion.
Cancer preventive and aging attenuation treatments may require
repetitive applications, and I can't tell you today, but I expect that
in the range of every 6 to 12 months to be needed.
No overt toxicity was observed, but long-term effects need to
be monitored, especially upon repeated applications.
With this, I think I have mentioned in particular the colleagues who
contribute to this work, and like to finish my presentation
to this double-edged
session that it's maybe not so double-edged if we
just eliminate in tight windows senescent cells
once in a while. Thanks for your attention.
Thanks, Clemens, for the very thought-provoking talk.
The senlyt is super exciting. I guess I'll ask the
first question. You've proven that it can eradicate senescent cells in so
many scenarios. If you took it into the clinic, what indication would
you first try, and why?
So we are at the level where we try to push
this agent through
pharmacokinetics and different species, and are close to
consider early testing in cancer settings.
I'm grateful for the question since we are at the AACR,
and heard about osteoarthritis. There are many diseases, age-related
pathologies, where senolysis or SAS modulation
may be very important. But we also talk about to bring those
candidate agents
actually at the bedside, bring it to clinical registration.
And I believe as an oncologist hematologist, that
probably the cancer space is the fastest way to
demonstrate efficacy and bring these agents to the clinic, and then
potentially into non-cancer settings.
I will take a question here.
Can I? Hi, wonderful talk. Thank you.
Thank you.
My question is maybe a naive question, but what about in
cancer heterogeneity, the probability to select
the most proliferative cells by using a senolytic drug?
This possibility is given since we will be targeting
obviously the senescent cells. But if I may say
so from changing the perspective, one of the most
critical problems in cancer is therapy
surviving persister cells, and these persisters are
typically low to non-proliferating cells, dormant
cancer cells with overlapping features to cellular senescence.
If we would get a handle on those cells by a senolytic
approach, we would probably make a major achievement.
And I'm certainly not arguing that this is all what it
takes to eliminate potentially
relapse-promoting cells. You might be very right, but I think the
therapy surviving slow to no proliferating
persisters are a central problem to target.
Thank you.